hey leute ich wollte euch heute mal call
of duty black meint 2 vorstellen und
zwar ist das natürlich in minecraft ist
gerade schon seht es ist nämlich call of
duty in minecraft dafür gibt es zwar
nicht
also es ist erstmal ein server und die
findet ihr auch in der beschreibung und
man braucht dafür ein spezielles texture
pack das ist aber alles beim download
mit enthalten welches es im plattform
gibt also ich hab euch das unten alles
war lync server usw
einfach draufklicken dann könnt ihr das
auch spielen und zwar könnt ihr hier
call of duty sage ich mal meinen kräften
hier sind gerade recht wenig leute drauf
was eigentlich sehr cooles weil ich das
dann ein bisschen zeigen kann aber nicht
sofort niedergemetzelt wird und zwar
wird das alles mit den komment blogs
sage ich mal geregelt und mein sport am
anfang erstmal hier da sieht man dort
kälter und ustream language von spam die
mystery boxster und lief dort lockt auto
in fighting also wenn man kämpft soll
man sich nicht ausschlagen ich denke wow
der emsländer minsk in na gut hier sind
noch die chance
dies gibt sage ich mal hier sind rekrut
und soulja als ich bin zurzeit sollte
surgeon general und veteran und naja
start lidl muss man hier auf den knopf
klicken war was soll ich jetzt gemacht
jetzt hab ich dann glaube ich irgendwo
drauf gedrückt
bin ich irgendwo jetzt muss man sich auf
jeden fall auf den knopf drücken wird
man hier ein spontan steht hierzu auch
klaas dann kann man sagen sniper als
solcher kann dort oder make los und ich
kann mich eigentlich nur juggernaut
empfehlen das mache ich jetzt mal
einfach bekommt man hier noch ein paar
sachen das war ganz einfach ein fehler
dass ich ein paar sachen bekommen habe
und zwar geht es hier los da sieht man's
power point sondern kann man hier sagen
wo man sparen will auf dem flugzeug im
wald in der farm in dem sniper haus und
helikopter oder einer submarine
ich kann mich eigentlich vorerst nur
empfehlen kann man natürlich direkt bei
den zombies höhe
hallo da mach ich fahren
so jetzt ist man hier direkt drin das
ist so die map das sind keine maps
direkt aus ahaus call of duty black ops
nachgebaut da oben sind zwei leute ich
glaube die machen team die maps sind
nicht direkt aus call of duty black ops
nachgebaut
haha ich hab mir runter geschubst mein
gott sondern es sind einfach so
ausgedachte map sage ich mal
aber das finde ich auch eigentlich ganz
gut rote karte sah verdammt online jetzt
zombies ort über die fläche wieder dir
sterben
jetzt sollte man nicht man muss halt
sich gegen einander bekämpfen da oben
sind zwei leute die machen team das ist
eigentlich nicht so heißen weil das
eigentlich ein ffh ist also frei falle
die call of duty spielen ist unglaublich
was fa ist
du wirst wohl kaum gegen mich jetzt auf
die entfernung mit beschwert kämpfen
können so und da der sinn des spiels das
halt einfach dass man sich gegenseitig
bekämpft und wenn man durch die
erfahrungspunkte kann man dann auch
dingens aufsteigen
warum kann man level aufsteigen also
klassen margot hätten ja mein schwert
ich nie im leben
das schaffe ich nie im leben der shaolin
leben das gott unendlich habe ich nicht
da bin ich tot ich würde sagen wir jetzt
eine andere klasse so hier auf den
schalter hier drauf drücken welche
klasse nehmen denn jetzt mal in dem
jetzt mal ist out class gibt mein
schwert muss mein schwert aus mein start
war gut und wir schauen jetzt mal in dem
sniper haus ist es aber eigentlich
relativ blöd wenn man direkt neben dem
mops pornos bond und sage ich mir von
hier oben zu leiten kann aber der
topscorer steht hier natürlich extra
ganz einfach aus dem grund es soll ja
nicht so einfach sein wenn man oben
bleiben will und kämpfen will
na gut ich würde sagen kann ich ihn dir
unter also meine beste runde war bisher
wirklich so dass ich die ganze zeit am
leben weil ich hab mich ein extra
umgebracht damit ich euch dass ihr
zeigen wo kontrolliert also die zombies
machen das alles halt noch ein bisschen
schwerer da unten ist eine person direkt
unter mir
und zwar ist das unter mir ganz witzig
dort ist nämlich
kommt man hier auch unternehmen kommt
nicht runter und zwar ist dort ein
riesiger raum da hinten ist auch eine
person dort hin
dort unten ist ein riesiger raum und
zwar was nach dieser raum sind kommen
blogs dort sind ganz ganz nett zombie
sodass es stockfinster
aber da sind glaube ich auch immer eine
menge items drin verstreut man findet
ihr auf der map immer so ein paar
alterns eigentlich ganz cool oh gott
jetzt verfolgt mich so viele zombies
ja ja ich weiß abteilungsleiter training
schaffe vor allem das ist ganz wenige
trainer auf mich drauf so wenig dass ich
nicht erobert moslems vom bia kommen
warum gehen die wahl auf mich auch nicht
auf ihn so wir machen das jetzt auch
einmal als ich wollte das eigentlich
ganz kurz zeigen aber es ist echt geil
mail icloud habe ich noch nie genommen
eigentlich viel besser als die andere
und ich würde sagen wir spornen mal bei
der submarine habe ich auch noch nicht
gespannt ob unter wasser hoch geht und
jetzt direkt bei den zombies auf gott oh
gott oh gott
ihr kommt auch in diesem fall wenn die
zionisten ein bisschen klüger und ein
bisschen schneller als im normalen
minecraft weil er keine ahnung kommt
nicht vor da hinten ist wieder einmal
spawn die in mir drin möchte auch für
apple hier
es gibt wirklich keinen richtigen platz
wo man wirklich komplett sicher ist vor
den zombies kann nicht sein alter
bekannt ihr euch mal geil hand liegen
sachen eltern ein
ich komme jetzt nicht hoch oder wie doch
ich dachte schon oh wow wow da ist
jemand drin
nein das kann nicht sein diese ganzen
verdammten gepackt zum ist meine sache
macht ihr zu reden das kann nicht sein
dass man immer von diesem verdammten
kommissar getötet wird kommen ihm etwas
nach vorn kämpfen bisschen rosaroter
klose kommen plain so wage ich hier in
der tür drin was das schön diese ruhe
aber ich sehe jetzt auch keine person
dauernd nissen person
ich komme jetzt einfach runter gott das
schaffe ich auch nicht das sind so diese
blöden leute die spielen immer mit
joggern ort die haben dann keine rüstung
und also die haben eine übels touristen
nicht sorgte hatte konnte ich leider gar
nichts zeigen und man hätte ich zehn
aufgenommen ich alle gebannt schaut
na gut dann will ich sagen das was
erstmal von call of duty black meint
zwei schauten die beschreibung könnt ihr
selber spielen ich bin hier sehr oft auf
dem bauch auf dem server kaufen das
relativ leer immer so wir sehen uns dann
bestimmt dann irgendwann natürlich sagen
sehen wir zwei nächsten video wie immer
wenn euch das video gefallen hat damit
eine positive wertung abgeben also
daumen hoch geben wenn es euch nicht
gefallen hat einen daumen runter der
sich was euch gefällt blabla kommentar
schreiben usw wissen wie es läuft dann
sehen uns beim nächsten mal